als willkommene zu der letzten ausgabe
vor fortsetzung folgt hit kids
wiedersehen mit der schweizer des jahres
2010 rolf maibach und marion kaufmann
hat nach schwarz bevor ich die kurve wo
not am markt die sich selbstlos gesetzt
für die opfer und für das sind noch die
schweiz auszeichnen toten im jahr 2002
[Applaus]
[Musik]
schweizer
bild zins bei mir zu gast und ich möchte
wissen wie das ist wenn man einfach
hilft wo hilfe nötig ist und man noch
harry der schweiz als held gefeiert wird
und was sie den großen moment damals
rasierte die kollekte patrick
schellenberg es nach der katastrophe auf
heute kreist
das erdbeben dauerte eine minute
[Musik]
eine minute in der 300.000 menschen
starben und noch viel mehr verletzt
worden
[Musik]
eine minute in der fast zwei millionen
menschen ihr zuhause verloren
eine minute nach der in haiti nichts
mehr so sein sollte wie es einmal war
eine minute die auch das leben von
raffaela und rolf maibach aus ilanz für
immer veränderte im januar 2010 lebt der
raphaela maybach mit ihrem mann rolf
schon über drei jahre in haiti
er leitete das hôpital albert schweitzer
auf der insel
[Musik]
als die erde bebte machten sie gerade
ferien in der schweiz rolf maibach
konnte sich bereits zwei tage nach dem
beben zum spital durchkämpfen sie alt
ihn nun hinterher eine gefährliche und
schmerzliche reise die bündnerin und ihr
mann setzen sich seit 1996 für die
medizinische versorgung der bitterarmen
bevölkerung ein
als die nachricht von der katastrophe
sie erreichte war für sie sofort klar
dass sie jetzt so sehr gebraucht würden
wie noch nie
un soldaten sollen plünderer abschrecken
ein endloser konvoi mit hilfslieferungen
bringt den verkehr zum erliegen
nach langen stunden im stau ist die
zerstörte hauptstadt durchquert jetzt
geht die reise noch drei stunden über
die berge bis nach dem appell
dort steht das hôpital albert schweitzer
[Musik]
raphaela maybach versucht seit tagen
ihren mann zu erreichen
doch das netz ist tot
nur einmal hatten sie kurz kontakt
der helikopter von roche kann endlich im
spital schweizer srg zwar sehr sehr weh
so können sie viele banker liegt überall
aber als ich sehr viel ruhiger weniger
hektisch als in der stadt
aber er hat relativ betrachtet am
nächsten morgen
raphaela maybach kam erst spät in der
nacht bei ihrem mann an bevor ein
hektischer arbeitstag im spital losgeht
können sie sich einige ruhige minuten
rolf maibach erzählt von den tagen nach
der katastrophe was mich fasziniert das
spielerische ruhig es normal rüber so
viel weiter sein lernen
dankbar natürlich auch was geschafft ein
pastoraler dir die ein größte tisch
die sind zum teil mit lastwagen sind die
einfachheit und also du hast du vor
stattlicher heißen der oberschenkelbruch
groß kostendrucks die 66 jährigen hat
vier erwachsene kinder
während 30 jahren betrieben sie eine
kinderarztpraxis im bündnerischen ilanz
jetzt ist rolf maibach direktor dieses
spitals seine frau raffaela leitet das
labor
[Musik]
sie hätten es sich im alltag gemütlich
machen können doch solange es solche
bilder gibt kommen sie nicht zur ruhe
[Musik]
das spital hat 120 betten und 500
angestellte finanziert wird es durch
spendengelder aus der schweiz und den
usa
weil das albert schweitzer spital als
eines der wenigen beim erdbeben
unbeschädigt blieb ist es nun völlig
überlastet
[Musik]
der kleine claude kommt mit seinen
eltern schon zum zweiten mal vorbei das
ist sehr sehr schwierige situation auch
für marica ich muss diese
krankenschwester sorgen und hat aber
sehr sehr starken klassik von der hand
13 kilo theoretisch die bombe
sehr positiv also sie sehen da sehr
geärgert aber sie sehen poesie hat hat
sich die ganzjahres ich verdrückt wurde
vor wohl darum sind das vergleicht
sicherung sehr sehr solch ein projekt
überhaupt retten
die eltern hoffen nun auf einen
amerikanischen handspezialisten der bald
in spittal eintreffen soll
raphaela maybach lässt sich von ihrer
stellvertreterin auf den neuesten stand
bringen
die situation sei prekär viele wichtige
medikamente und utensilien seien
ausgegangen
der dringend benötigten nachschub aus
büro preis sei unterbrochen
doch das personal hat noch ganz andere
sorgen
manchmal so sagt euch jetzt
die heckseite dass sie weder die familie
mitglied im europäischen die
verlorenheit sie hatte keine kontakt mit
tanner besitz und sie glauben immer da
dass das sehr viel
es ist natürlich sehr traurig sie hätte
eigentlich soll ein problem hat sie
ständig aber sehr gedrückt ist eine
klappe italiener blickt es erst am
mittwoch und dann ist natürlich klar sie
haben es ihnen ergangen
marion kaufmann arbeitet seit
zweieinhalb jahren als krankenschwester
im albert schweitzer spital
sie spricht die landessprache kreolisch
fließen
die bernerin hatte gerade dienst als das
erdbeben kam wenige stunden später
trafen die ersten schwer verletzten ein
seither arbeitet sie ununterbrochen
bisschen sagt sie um ein gespräch
irgendwas er wieder zurück und seien für
viele ihrer patienten müssen tagelang
mit unbehandelten verletzungen ausharren
die operationssäle sind überlastet doch
niemand beklagt sich es herrscht eine
eigentümliche ruhe
ist es die stille dankbarkeit überlebt
zu haben ist es der schock nach der
katastrophe oder ist es die reaktion von
menschen die in einem land leben wo man
schon immer viel ertragen musste und
nichts erwarten durfte aber das ist
wahnsinnig schwierig und jetzt wieder 23
am polohemd der geest unterschiede zu
früher jetzt gezielt und nachhaltig mit
schwarzem patienten sind da ist
der von der trage und einfach schon
immer groß ich habe hoffentlich und vor
allem ein unheimlicher gab es wegen
nicht um wirklich das schaffen
das spitalpersonal muss ohnmächtig
zuschauen wie die patienten leiden
die schmerzmittel sind nach den
dramatischen letzten tagen restlos
aufgebraucht
in ganz haiti väter naschen
[Musik]
auch im labor von raphaela maybach ist
die situation kritisch praktisch leer
alle konzerte sind schnell erfassen
der mittlere damit ich haben eine lage
wie viel man im vorrat hand und wenn man
wirklich mehr sind knapp das sind didier
konzerns testet sind der ist praktisch
leer
das ist alles was ich so erfordert
konzept parat sind zum muster arbeit
wir hätten da schon ein ziemlicher vor
ort
aber das sind alles konzerne hiv
hepatitis b hepatitis syphilis testet
sind und das wird aber nicht gemacht
sondern im rock hits in progress und ich
weiß dass sie im moment nicht schafft
die sind ich weiß eine genauer
geschädigt das gebäude gehört der
sehgeschädigte als auch mehr gewicht
doch genau diese schnelltests sind nun
auch ausgegangen
[Musik]
marion kaufmann wohnt in einem
angestellten haus auf dem gelände des
spitals acht tage nach dem erdbeben
genehmigt sie sich ihren ersten freien
tag
es gibt momentan und krippe lag ja
letztens immer versucht sich lieber für
mich familie aber ich merke ich dass man
natürlich schlecht geht dass im moment
im moment jetzt aber nicht für mich ich
habe noch nichts verdrängen
aber nicht als hochkultur belecker was
haben jetzt aus sagt marion kaufmann
sagt sie sei in den letzten tagen
übermüdet und oft gereizt gewesen
nun hat sie endlich wieder einmal zeit
für ihren mann den haitianer patrick
bardelli er fast nebenbei erzählt sie
dann noch dass sie vier tage nach dem
erdbeben einige stunden frei machte um
schnell zu heiraten
die hochzeit sei seit längerem geplant
gewesen sie hätten sich entschieden
trotz oder gerade wegen der katastrophe
ein zeichen für die zukunft zu setzen
tot ist
was war
ja
dass es bisher lisboa rolf maibach
stellt der mutter des kleinen claude
einem handspezialisten aus atlanta vor
[Musik]
der arm des kleinen claude war so stark
geschwollen dass seine hand nicht mehr
durchblutet wurde
deshalb mussten die ärzte den arm
aufschneiden um den druck zu vermindern
im vorderrad entlastet denn nachher
stirbt der momentan mini mini frösche
oder mini mini angst offen
und er meint dass zeta und für sich
recht zur schlachtung summer music
defekten vor dem vor dem schnitt der hut
transplantation und das weitermachen
hand aber das gerät für hier speziell
transplantation einig aber das hält die
mit dem prosecco und denken sich die
zweifel kann man die transportation
machen um die hand rechten oder und und
ein muss vor allem keine tanz selber
bewegen um für das bruchsaler hilfe das
buch der physiotherapie und mehr händler
die einzig physiotherapie im ganzen raum
dollar und mit physiotherapeut dabei ist
wirklich einfach ein richtiges spital
nach hause
der kleine claude wird kräftige hände
brauchen seine generation ist die
zukunft haitis dieses geschundenen
landes das aus den trümmern neu
entstehen muss
begrüßt mir ganz herzlich raffaela und
rolf maibach und marion kaufmann
webportal heißt seit der hochzeit
einfach wie gott zum code welcher sie
ziehen nach und also die grundsätzlich
gute holt man halt wirklich nach zwei
oder drei haben wir die transportation
könne mache meinte maschinenbau und der
army schwor und tanzt mit intensiver
physiotherapie sich wieder seine private
und die schwierige frage wie geht's
heute kann man das einfach so statuen
von einem land im wiederaufbau dass sich
fragt wo man natürlich nicht so einfach
beantworten aber sieht man vor allem
jetzt in offenburg sehe dass es doch
fortschritte in der hauptstadt bei aus
dem spital sowieso mit kinderabteil wie
tritt man filme patient der wilden
flüchtlingen jahres teilhaben das vom
rbb also wie ist es die frage einfach
sie sind ja damals passiert ist die
schwierigste schwitzen denn sie
produzieren ein szenario von dem ausmaß
der katastrophe kommt also ich kann da
nicht übers fernsehen und ich wusste ich
muss so schnell wie möglich zurück das
ist mit 90
angst habe ich einfach toll als ziel
kann so schnell wie möglich zurück und
der küste hinweg schon mit der
gruppenweiten ist und ich habe mir für
mich selber lagen wenig spiele ca 30
burg sie hat nicht gewusst wie er nicht
das ist dann aber gut ganz bewundert sie
sind bald in pension sollte der satz wo
sich gleich den vorherrscht und der neue
krise an sie ein sehr einfach vor
weltgrößten bemüht das machen da gibt es
gar keine frage
also für mich ich mag sie ja so misst 16
blieben und machen weiter machen
nach wahrheit die ich euch mal auf den
heimischen pisten und das ist so viel
zug überrollt das ist ja das warum wir
immer wieder wettgemacht so vielfältig
dass ein magnet oder häufiges wort wohl
nicht gar nicht zu sagen haben das ist
arbeit fasziniert
es ist einfach ein bisschen fasziniert
sagte frauke das klingt aber längst
schon behaupten das könnt ihr nun
passiere ich das nie hätte ich das nicht
da hab ich denn ist solidarität einmal
im vordergrund und hotel wie sie in die
optik sie was passiert ist und einfach
abgeschafft ist das als ob sie gar nicht
überlegt machen oder einzige moment das
gefühl über hoffe das maß verloren
einkommens aber mich stört die haben
dort geführt ich hab' ich habe mich
zweite heimat so und na ja ich fahre
weiter und damit verbunden über das ist
das no me ist vielfältig
also ich habe ja nur im urlaub damit
jung und somit dort integriert habe ich
sage ich habe mich dort mein geschmähte
heimisch fühlt aussetzer zwei stühlen
hier nicht wissen wie schützt man sich
in so eine extreme stresssituation kaka
r schickt das muss ich wieder bevor ja
glaub wir haben ja die scheibe forderte
dabei das buch nach auszustellen sie
litt wie viele halten und dass ich im
spital hat man mit dieser zeit nimmst
der situation überfordert automat
was sagen die schweiz das ja alles für
sie braucht nur wenig zu bewegen war es
ging eigentlich dürfen
engagiert aber es könnte zur freude und
es braucht um sich dann profitieren oder
wofür der verein profitiert also von ihr
haben mich für mittlere plätze durch
sehr engagiert also wirklich an den weg
machen natürlich auf spender für dieses
spiel setzen dass er sich im film
brachte interesse und herr zwischen der
schweiz und heute eigentlich wohne jetzt
in der schweiz aber der maybach ist im
führungsgremium vom arbeitskreis spital
immer engagiert ein augenschein in new
york nach der großen katastrophe
[Musik]
aig im vergangenen november
raphaela maybach ist wieder unterwegs
zum ob ital albert schweitzer
doch diesmal ist sie nicht alleine
diesmal reiste gemeinsam mit ihrem mann
rolf in die heimat ihrer herzen die
festanstellung im spital haben die
beiden aufgegeben
sie leben wieder in der schweiz drei
oder viermal pro jahr besuchen sie haiti
[Musik]
ganz stark und ich glaube dass vögel
mehr habe ich auch um information sei
nachher das macht macht was nicht seit
ich einfach das gefühl von leichtigkeit
und fröhlichkeit oma doch einfach wieder
plötzlich wo man vielleicht in der
schweiz nicht unbedingt wenn man
herkommt
die farbe ist zurückgekehrt in das leben
der menschen
doch noch immer leidet die bevölkerung
unter großer armut
raffaela und rolf maibach sind pausenlos
daran für das albert schweitzer spital
spenden zu sammeln
ihre sogenannte bündner partnerschaft
ist der wichtigste geldgeber des spitals
der hoffnung
[Musik]
ramona
die zweite heimat von raffaela und rolf
maibach ist nach dem erdbeben bald aus
den nachrichten verschwunden
[Musik]
rolf maibach freut sich dass die cholera
abteilung des spitals für einmal fast
leer steht seit dem erdbeben wurde die
insel von zwei schweren cholera
epidemien heimgesucht in den vier jahren
die das paar hier lebte sind viele
freundschaften entstanden
[Musik]
ihre ankunft hat sich bereits
herumgesprochen
rolf maibach ist jetzt stiftungsrat des
spitals seine frau raffaela sorgt als
präsidentin der bündner partnerschaft
dafür dass viele ambitionierte projekte
des spitals mit spendengeldern
finanziert werden können
das hôpital albert schweitzer hat heute
deutlich mehr patienten als vor dem
erdbeben
nach der katastrophe flüchteten rund 160
tausend menschen aus der hauptstadt und
ließen sich im einzugsgebiet des spitals
nieder
rolf maibach begleitet seine
nachfolgerin bei der visite die
schweizerin silvia ernst trat ihre
stelle als medizinische direktorin kurz
nach dem erdbeben an
es sind halt mangelnde hygiene mängeln
die sagen der richtige wo halt nur für
cholera sony für infektionskrankheiten
durch frankreich als basis sind dass die
verpflichtung als ehemaliger direktor
und als mitglied des finanz komitees ist
rolf maibach ein wichtiger
gesprächspartner des generaldirektors
marta dieser hat seine stelle erst vor
einem monat angetreten
doch das erdbeben hat auch in seinem
beruf einen festen platz
dieses erdbeben ist wie eine trennlinie
es gibt ein leben davor und ein leben
danach das datum hat sich im gedächtnis
der menschen eingebrannt und das selbst
bei leuten aus dem ausland die hier
arbeit
raphaela maybach lässt sich von ihrer
nachfolgerin er sei auf den neuesten
stand bringen
das labor konnte dank spendengeldern aus
der schweiz renoviert und mit modernen
geräten ausgerüstet werden
eines sieht freut mich natürlich sehe
wirklich gut und ordentlich schaffen und
der andere mit wehmut ich hätte gern
natürlich schöner labor auch schafft das
ist vor allem möglich anders ist der
neueste stolz des spitals ist die
mikrobiologie die deutsche birgit gast
hat schon im albert schweitzer spital in
gabun gearbeitet
sie weiß was es braucht um in einem
tropischen land ohne infrastruktur eine
abteilung für mikrobiologie zu betreiben
hier können krankheitserreger bestimmt
und die wirksamkeit von antibiotika
getestet werden
rolf maibach ging es nie um seine
karriere in bewegen die menschen von
haiti
[Musik]
er ist sich auch als stiftungsrat nicht
zu schade für eine
ultraschalluntersuchung einzuspringen
eine junge ärztin schaut ihm über die
schulter
[Musik]
position
der meldet sich die erst einmal mit
haitianischen erst sechs gehören über
sie sprechen sollte das pedal wohl
vorhat jahre geführt wer wird also ganz
sicher zur kommt von dem land damit der
arbeitsplatz immer energiebedarfs die
prothesen abteilung ist nach dem
erdbeben neu entstanden unzählige
menschen verloren unter den
tonnenschweren trümmerteilen arme und
beine
die haitianischen prothesen techniker
sind begnadete handwerker ausgebildet
wurden sie von spezialisten aus der
schweiz und den usa
vor dem erdbeben schlugen sie sich als
brotlose kunst handwerker durch
sie gehören zu den ganz wenigen menschen
für die das erdbeben positive
auswirkungen hatte ja das ist zu wenig
aber es hat immer gewollt
ich habe vorwiegend welche kunst gemacht
was kommen können verkaufen
seit jahren auch ein prothese machen
habe nach dem beben passten die
techniker pro woche bis zu 40 neue
prothesen an
dies war zeitweise die größte prothesen
werkstatt der westlichen welt ein
trauriger rekord war endlich stress und
das ist ein spruch nichts bringt ist
schenk wo ausgerechnet einigkeit sich
eine spalte bei verloren ihrem erfolg
von der mafia www vier sind sind wir
mitten im park sie nach märkten der
prothese gemacht jetzt wieder laufen und
jährlich die andere patienten
aufgefallen
[Musik]
raffaela und rolf maibach wollen jene
frau besuchen die in den schwersten
stunden ihres lebens anderen patienten
mit einem lächeln mut spendete am
nächsten morgen machen sie sich auf den
weg nach europa
[Musik]
august soll eine c-klasse
und da ist es wieder
jenes lächeln einer frau die ihr leben
unter schwersten bedingungen meistern
muss egal wie sehr schmerzt wenn sie
jetzt ein klub ist spital zum morgen zum
die prothese für besser
[Musik]
das ist natürlich damit ja frohsinn nein
entwurf geschichte verzeichnen was gott
geringste problem aber wieder muss die
schmerzenden prothesen sind nur eines
von vielen problemen der allein
erziehenden mutter sie ist dankbar für
die unterstützung von raffaela und rolf
maibach mit der seele erzählt die
situation sei sehr schwierig wegen ihrer
behinderung finden sie keine arbeit und
könne darum ihre vier kinder nur schwer
ernähren
[Musik]
lächle jedes mal wenn du gestresst bist
ihr lächeln müssen sich die menschen von
haiti hart erkämpfen
die trümmer sind weggeräumt der alltag
ist zurückgekehrt
doch es ist noch immer der alltag in
einem der ärmsten länder der welt
[Musik]
die schweizer besuchen eine freundin die
sie nach dem erdbeben als patientin im
spital kennenlernten
alex hat beim erdbeben ein bein verloren
ihr außergewöhnlicher wille und ehrgeiz
haben raffaela und rolf maibach tief
beeindruckt die 28 jährige wuchs als
waisenkind auf und musste sich schon vor
dem erdbeben alleine durch boxen ihr
volkswirtschaftsstudium hat sie sich mit
teilzeitjobs hart erarbeitet stolz zeigt
sie ein foto ihrer diplomfeier um auf
dem arbeitsmarkt konkurrenzfähig zu sein
muss ich besser sein als die anderen
viele haben einen universitätsabschluss
wie auch aber ich habe ein bein weniger
als wenn ich einen mastertitel machen
könnte würde dass meine chancen auf
einen job erhöhen
und dann wünsche ich mir noch eine
prothese mit der ich ganz normal laufen
kann
das ist mein traum mehr blind gar nichts
führt ihre besucher auf einen hügel am
rand von boro preis hier stand ihrer
universität wo heute eine lücke klafft
waren früher die hörsäle in denen die
junge haitianerin studierte als die erde
bebte gelang es ihr nicht aus dem
gebäude zu flüchten
eine betonmauer stürzte auf sie erst
nach zehn stunden konnte sie geborgen
werden mehr blind kann ist kämpft weiter
für ihre träume und sie hat raffaela und
rolf maibach an ihrer seite die sie auf
den steinigen weg unterstützen
[Musik]
marion und ihrem haitianische mal
herzlich willkommen
ja frau frau zu 100 tieren nicht dass
ein glücksfall wenn zurücktrat ist
richtiges später auch und mit der
verletzung aber wieder mit ihrer
ausbildung also ich find ich als großes
glück dass sie zu ihm nach
die proteste will die frau hätte ein
kühler villa am tag gleiter als
studierter bis zu diplom eric und sie
haben jetzt im film sehen
der master machen will sie mir besonders
gut sie wenn sie behinderte und mit der
behinderung wenn sie bewiesen dass sie
ist genauso gut können wir anderen ja
und
das bewohnte unheimlich aber situation
für behinderte ist ja ganze land wie der
schweiz machen mit da noch keine partie
wo im rollstuhl sitzt also das ist schon
ganz andere ausgangslage aus der schweiz
es ist einfach alles viel härter wenn
man keinen fall ist für sich hier manche
sind völlig auf sich selber wiesenfest
familie war verhelfen aber es braucht
einen unheimlichen willen und darum sind
natürlich möglich denn eigentlich das
was tiger zum tag gemacht oder
überlebenswillens ganz schwierigste
situation erregen
doch das beste zu machen dass ich das
war fasziniert und weimar so viel zurück
manche waren denn wieder einmal mit und
zeigen dass du hast beruf gemacht und er
seien zurzeit das ist ja ein große tanz
über die motivation für sie zum wieder
schaffe der barthélemy sie hand aber ein
heutiger kilometer britische warum hat
sie sich entschieden ihre heimat ohne
diese bleibe nämlich sämtliche
unschlüssig seca nach zwei jahren
geschlossen geschwister nicht verpassen
[Gelächter]
also man kann sich schon vorstellen mit
der mauer länger sind bereits gesehen
die sehr viel zukunft vor ihrem sohn hat
er keine chance gute chance
bis 16 der schuh ist für mich ganz klar
ist also für mich baby du siehst ja ich
höre die aufnehmen augen sei die von der
verwandtschaft für jedermann auf
persönliche kanal vista läuft es wieder
gott der widerruf was sind das für news
über mit verschiedenen und seiner
familie wohnt hat das feld
und mit herrlichen konter und
diskutieren hengste unterschiedliche
konnte also ja informationen
hauptfiguren etwas bietet die fahrt
läuft eigentlich positiv also das ist
eigentlich glaubt generell positiv
stellen also sie sind noch unentschieden
in zukunft völlig normal verlaufen beide
länder die märkte unter anderem zwischen
spinne ich habe gesagt sie sind über
unser auto sie können sie schon
längstens auf den lorbeeren ausruhen
godzilla auf das dass ich sicher kam es
in der meisten sie nicht sondern drei
vier mal im jahr ermordet in haiti zum
projekt kontrollieren und mitgliedschaft
verlagert dass man wichtige schritt
freuen sich natürlich die ganze welt
das spital aber weiterhin finanzieren
das ist sehr viel arbeit vortrag und so
tritt erst heimat also das möchte ja
sagen von thermischer traktors der titel
schweizer des jahres brauchte frage sie
sind wie im raum eigentlich an die
wahrheit der prise probe natürlich
mitgemeint sieht es ganz klar nicht das
hätte ich das nicht stört mich eins
überhaupt nicht stört ich habe sogar
toll gefunden dass man einmal über zwei
generationen für seinen titel quält will
dass sie eigentlich auch für jugend in
der schweiz motivieren sie dass sie
genau die jungen alles ein bisschen
klirren und das hat nicht stattgefunden
es braucht unser verein jetzt sieht
deine zwei jahre also natürlich sehr
viele früchte projekt wo mehr über
bündner partnerschaften finanziert hat
sehr viele spender geht das ist sicher
sehr positives zeichen sind über
präsident pinera sie lehnt die von der
partnerschaft um mehr hoffe jetzt so
lange wie möglich solange sie ist gott
und mit uns gelänge mit ihrem er immer
wieder günter stauer besser gottes und
solange das geld machen wird dass man
immer wieder zu können das ist aber
möglichkeit zu klagen was fast an eine
wirkliche regierung bedeutet und wie man
mit mancher so auf der schanze und dass
das macht peter könnte es rufen mit dem
verstand es war vor allem fähig nicht so
verständlichkeit für so aufgabe hielt
richter war der gedanke mit
konzertmeister jeremy welt zu mir noch
nie ganz so sicher ich bedanke mich ganz
herzlich für hotel bahia sie böse sind
messe jeremy das duo ausgiebig und das
heißt sie ist gottes sorge
das war die letzte die fortsetzung folgt
muster serie zeug und rita und ich bin
überzeugt das geht aus nach stetiger
ganze geschichte zu erzählen wie es
wieder gang ist im leben von menschen
und man ihnen vorgestellten die das
handy reporter oder doch ganz einfach
das interesse
[Musik]